FERNANDA DE LA TORRE: The
brain's ability to imagine
is a fascinating mystery.
I grew up in Mexico, and my
small family crossed the border
because we imagined a better
life in the United States.
Later, I escaped an abusive
home because I imagined a better
future for myself.
And much later, my
imagination inspired
me to dream of having a
job where I could ponder
the largest questions of life.
I'm Fernanda De La Torre, and
at the McGovern Institute,
I use math to study how
our brain understands
the difference between
imagination and reality.
Let me give you an example.
Follow the motion
of this pink cube.
Do you imagine it dropping
onto the purple surface
or sliding down a ramp?
It's hard to tell, right?
That's because the
visual clues are vague,
and the movement
of the pink cube
could be caused by different
physical realities.
Now, what if I pair the same
video with a sound clue?
[SCRAPING SOUND]
Now it's obvious.
The cube is clearly
sliding down the ramp.
That's because
your brain combined
the visual clues
and the sound clues
to determine what was really
happening with the cube.
I use artificial
neural networks,
or a series of math
equations, to understand
how the brain makes these
important mental calculations
so that we can distinguish
imagination from reality.